- Welcome back, everybody!
(audience clapping)
It is National Sock Day, which was created
by the next three guests that are here.
They're the founders of Pair of Thieves,
a clothing company that happens
to make super comfy socks.
If you know me at all,
all my friends know that
I'm obsessed with socks.
Like, you know people
get that for Christmas?
I love getting socks for Christmas.
Anyway, but you know,
family members are like,
why did you give me socks?
Give me socks.
Anyway, and what started out
(audience laughing)
as a fun idea has turned into
a deeply meaningful mission,
which is even better.
Please welcome Alan Stewart,
David Ehrenberg and
Cash Warren, everybody.
(audience cheering)
So, welcome to the show.
- Thank you so much.
- You guys have been friends for a minute,
right?
- We have.
We grew up together.
You know, when I had the idea
to start Pair of Thieves,
I knew I'm not a mister know-it-all,
I don't have all the answers.
- Yeah, I love it.
- And so, I knew I needed partners
to take the idea and
make it a bit stronger.
And so, I reached out
to two childhood friends
to help me launch.
- We've been at this for
31 years of friendship.
- Oh, my gosh.
- Yes.
- I love those friends.
- And starting a business
is like a marriage.
- Yeah.
Well, sometimes it doesn't work out.
I hope the best for you.
(audience and guests laughing)
So I've heard.
So, how did the sock thing happen?
Where did that come from?
Why socks?
- So, we knew there was an
opportunity to make better socks.
When we started this, like, 10 years ago,
there just weren't good socks out there.
And so, we said, can we take style,
performance and affordability
and mash them all up?
And that was what gave
birth to Pair of Thieves.
- Yeah, I love the name too.
It's such a cool name.
So, tell us about the cause behind this.
- Yeah, I mean, when we were
out one day as a company,
giving socks out to people in
need, living on the streets,
we got this guy who
came up to me and said,
you know, these are like
gold when you're homeless.
And so, at that moment, we
knew that something small
could turn into something big.
And since then, we've partnered up
with a great organization
called Baby2Baby,
and we've donated over
3 million pairs of socks
together.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- You don't think about that,
but that would be something
that's, like, shoes or socks,
like, I never really thought
about that, but that-
- It's super important.
- Yeah.
- Super important,
and they have to be donated new.
You don't donate used socks,
and so it takes companies
like ours to step up and really
try to make a difference.
- Yeah.
- And so, we started National
Sock Day as kind of a fun,
lighthearted way to raise
attention and raise awareness.
- How do you get a
national day for something?
- It's really funny.
- It's so cool.
So, we were really jealous
(audience cheering)
of tacos getting Tuesday.
- (sighs) Love Taco Tuesday.
(audience laughing)
- So, we were like, how do
we get to one for socks?
And there is a National
Day Calendar organization
that governs all these
kind of random day holidays
that you see popping up everywhere.
And we applied, we wrote an essay
and of the 18,000-
- You wrote an essay.
I've never seen you work harder.
- I know, yeah, yeah.
(audience laughing)
- I will get this sock day!
- (laughs) I will get it!
- I love it.
- And we were awarded the day.
And so, December 4 is National Sock Day.
- Love it!
- Today, it is very much
a day of service for the company.
We volunteer at organizations.
This year, we're
volunteering at Baby2Baby.
- Yeah.
- In the past,
we've donated at shelter partnerships
and a number of others.
But it feels good to get
out and to really recognize,
something so small can make
the biggest difference in someone's life.
- 100%, and how cool is it
that you get to do it with,
like, friends that you've grown up with
and you get to do something, like,
that you love to do together,
but also is an impact,
like, in the world?
That's cool.
Well, what's the bigger
mission of the company?
What's the big thing?
- So, you know, we started
out as a sock brand,
but as our products have
expanded to underwear
and to shirts and, you know,
the customer base has expanded,
our give back has as
well, and so today we have
a wonderful partnership
with an organization
called The Trevor
Project, for LGBTQ youth.
- Yeah, yeah.
(audience clapping)
- And, thank you, we donate
hundreds of thousands of dollars
in product to that
organization every year.
We're all dads, and so teen mental health
is incredibly important to us.
And so, we support an organization
called Bring Change to Mind,
and then as Alan mentioned,
Baby2Baby is our partnership
for families in need.
- Yeah, it's so funny.
We all have children here.
I think when we were all kids,
mental health was still
a very important thing,
but I think social media has just
really just blown up everything.
And it's more important now than ever
for kids to really have great self-esteem.
All right, so how can
everybody get involved?
What should they do?
- You know, in honor
of us being here today,
we wanted to announce that, you know,
for December 4 and December 5,
everything on pairofthieves.com,
we'll donate 100% of our
net proceeds to charity.
And so-
- Wow!
- Thank you.
(audience clapping)
So, if you're looking for a great gift,
know that you're purchasing with a purpose
and we're gonna support organizations.
- Purchasing with a purpose.
That should be a shirt.
It should be a sweatshirt y'all make.
I would buy that too.
(Cash laughing)
That's so nice!
But that's really cool.
Everybody, for more information
on how you can make a difference
this National Sock Day,
'cause they worked hard for that,
there was an essay, people,
head to our socials.